this is a talk about Bruce Lee on
programming because you may not know but
Bruce Lee was very much into learning in
his whole life and as it turned out he
actually learned a little bit about
programming was the early 70s not quite
the program we know today but he did
learn about program and it be very clear
once you study his writings that he was
his the things he his writings are
basically timeless and still apply today
so what did he have to say about coding
it's not the daily increase but the
daily I'm not gonna read them all but
who hasn't done that where you remove
code instead of adding code you're like
oh that is that is wonderful also this
is where the word hacking came from
refactoring
he's completely correct about
refactoring here read fast prototyping I
like this one he actually used to say it
all the time call it dryland swimming
you did that that gets you nowhere no
one in no one in the world was more in
the zone than Bruce Lee right obviously
you must be in a relaxed state to be
proficient on object-oriented
programming this is one of my favorites
the more you value things less we buy
yourselves he was not a very he didn't
like object-oriented programming also
didn't like design patterns the truth is
outside all fixed patterns agile he
spent very much into agile you can
imagine how agile II he needed to be
yeah yes very nice very very much of a
scrum there yep thank you
oh this was one this one's from Jackie
which I don't know I was looking I mean
oh I've read all of bruce lee's writing
I couldn't quite exactly find this quote
found quote that was very similar but I
assume this is completely correct so
ownership semantics this is very true
like if your once you write a class you
have to decide in your mind first what
are the ownership semantics before you
apply them to your code bounds checking
turns out yeah I was surprised by this
that he was against bound checking so I
asked him about it and he said this
there are no limits and you know if your
program dies your program dies like so
that's that's what he had to say about
kind of programming in general but what
about C++ itself right he had things to
say about C++ in particular standard
variant understood santur variant
completely in order to taste my cup of
water you must first empty your cup
switching that switching the types on
assignment and so also he was also you
know a regular I asked him Matt asked me
to ask him about regular void he was I
don't know what the thing if the cups
are like he's very often came up with
cup stuff also on the C++ committee many
people don't know that yeah yeah cups
are containers I was gonna mine x
container is gonna be called cup B not
for nor against I was surprised by this
I I thought he'd be more opinionated but
at least he was eating they wouldn't
take sides he wasn't very political on
the committee that was nice
oh this one this moves semantics I I
didn't know this I talked to Howard
about this it turns out he worked with
Howard on new semantics but he didn't
want to get take credit he was very and
I read this one and honestly I didn't
understand it
and so I asked Howard about it and he
explained it to me because you know how
I think I was actually happy as long as
Howard understood it I was okay cuz mu
semantics but he said look at vector and
when you do a vector move when you move
in a vector the underlying memory stays
still it was this was actually the
insight that led to mu semantics default
comparison he was also concerned about
this I think it's what when he left the
committee he's just like you know what
it's just what is there's no compare be
peaceful oh also the seatpost work or
guidelines obey the principles without
being bound by them including the
principle of gravity I guess it just
didn't really apply to him okay that's
another talk same same same idea one of
the rules like a pro brick and like an
artist I need you to in a minute this is
this is what he had to say about you
know how to be proficient how to get
efficient code he's like do not fight
the compiler just just let the compiler
do it right the code simply and then
okay here we go next slide so if you
look carefully though he's he's on two
fingers but but the goal has not always
been to be reached it's often circe
invasive so I'm aiming for the two
fingers I haven't got there yet okay and
actually this is this is real I I this
is how I code we have a problem at work
and it's like well what would we really
love this code to look like in at the
end of the day and we may never get
there but as you're coding along just
try to head in the right direction uh
coding style and I agree with this I've
given up having coding style I just go
with whatever's there
I'm getters and setters it's not what
you give it's the way you give it I have
pictures for this it's not what you give
it's the way you give it
and yes that was Chuck Norris and I'm
sure you want to see that again
Oh
since this this company now at so many
other languages during this conference I
he had something to say about other
languages this is you know fighting off
other languages and okay this has
nothing to hang I just think it's a good
quote and you like it that's it
[Applause]